the jurgen experience
we don't have much time you have a heart
out in one minute i just want to know
what what do you think goes down in
november and how hopeful are you for the
future
because it seems to me like we're [ __ ]
no matter who wins because the chaos
that we're seeing the civil unrest we're
seeing
it's going to either accelerate or or or
or spread one way or the other so i
think that
if we're going to hold together we have
to make a decision either fundamentally
the american system is good but flawed
we need to work on the flaws within the
system
or fundamentally the american system
sucks and was rooted in slavery and
bigotry and need to rip down the entire
system
the latter is not really a great recipe
so we can have normal political
arguments within the former or the
country is toast as far as what goes
down in november look right now the
polling data says trump gets skunked
i mean right now the polling data's got
biden up 10 12 points in the polls but
didn't the polling data in 2016 say that
hillary was going to steamroll
on the national data nuts on the
national data they were kind of right so
on the national data the final real
clear politics poll average was like
three points
hillary won by three points in the
popular vote the state polls were really
were really wrong particularly in
wisconsin and michigan and pennsylvania
on this one because trump is universally
losing in like all the swing states and
is in spitting distance in texas
he's got a lot of ground to make up
right now listen biden is running almost
the ideal campaign he's not alive he's a
not alive person
and as it turns out beating a dead horse
is actually kind of tough
right he's like because
he's not threatening he's fundamentally
non-threatening you look at biden do you
feel threatened by i don't feel
threatened by
and the man's not alive you can't
threaten me with a corpse right and so
and so
trump who is innately volatile and
looking for something to kind of attack
is his own worst enemy is his own worst
enemy like with hillary
the untold story of 2016 is that trump
didn't win hillary lost people
hated hillary's guts and the stat that
proves it is that people who hated both
trump and hillary
broke for trump pretty heavily right now
people who don't like either biden or
trump are breaking nearly universally
for biden
because trump is so off-putting and he
you know i've said for a long time
politics is about the art of making it
hard to vote for your opponent and easy
to vote for you
and trump is fairly good at number one
and he is awful he is god awful at
number two
making it easy to vote for him that
that's that's a toughy
[Applause]